oh god people are still eating charcoal
what the [ __ ] hey everyone i'm abby
sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by talkspace
and we will be reviewing fitness and
lifestyle youtuber daisy keach so i know
i am all over the place right now i'm
just trying to get settled in a
temporary filming situation as there's
some work going on in my studio but let
me tell you about my sponsor talk space
you guys know i have been pretty open
about my mental health struggles
throughout my life and i am a huge
proponent of therapy for anyone who has
access like seriously who doesn't
benefit from a supportive empathetic
person to talk to so i was really
excited when i learned about what this
new app talkspace is doing to make
therapy
more accessible and affordable for
everyone so talkspace is an online
platform for connecting people with a
licensed therapist that best meets their
goals and needs you basically just fill
out a quick online survey
get sent a list of recommended
therapists that best meets your needs
and then you can access sessions
securely online from anywhere
you can do live video sessions text and
audio messages whatever is most
convenient for you and as a busy person
i really love this flexibility it just
makes finding a therapist and actually
going to therapy that much easier so if
you've been thinking about prioritizing
your mental well-being this app is an
amazing place to start and you can check
out my link in the description and use
my promo code abbytalk to get a hundred
dollars off of your first session
but first my disclaimer that you can see
on the screen or in the description
including a trigger warning as i will be
discussing calories and macros so feel
free to skip that section if this does
not support your journey all right let's
get into it
i also want to mention i am not a
nutritionist by the way this is just
what works for me
always here for a disclaimer like this
so thank you so much i usually intuitive
eat so i don't have like a
strict suit
i don't know i kind of like intuitive
eat mixed with counting macros so like i
listen to my body and what i feel like
it needs but i also try to stay within
like a certain guideline so
not intuitively eat
you know i used to be a little bit salty
when folks were co-opting the intuitive
eating language
because you know if you're counting
macros and staying within a guideline
you're not actually intuitively eating
as it was conceptualized by its creators
so intuitive eating is actually a
mind-body framework that goes far beyond
just listening to your body and even if
it was just listening to your body
i would say it's not accurate to
describe what daisy is doing as eating
intuitively when we count macros make
sure that we're staying within a caloric
guideline or carefully follow a meal
plan uh we're really eating in response
to external cues not internal ones so
intuitive eating at its core is really
grounded in the idea of eating by
internal cues hence the word intuitive
now daisy didn't go into a whole lot of
detail on how she eats but i do get the
sense that what she means by intuitive
eating is that she's not like starving
or going hungry or even weighing or
carefully measuring her food like a lot
of folks in the fitness industry often
do so maybe because she's like
eyeballing it or she's allowing herself
to eat a bit more if she feels you know
she's working out or she feels super
hungry
that she sees this as the intuitive way
and i think it's actually a really great
step i really do so i'm not poo pooing
this effort here
but that to me could be more accurately
described as like flexible dieting
not intuitive eating and if flexible
dieting is what works for daisy
great
flexible dieting works for a lot of
people and i don't think that there's
anything wrong with it but intuitive
eating as it was conceptualized isn't
really compatible with the idea of
intentionally trying to get a flat tummy
and a big booty like her video title
suggests obviously this can happen for a
lot of folks who eat intuitively if that
is what their body is genetically
destined to look like but manipulating
your diet to achieve this look really
does miss the mark on that regard
anyways you can eat however you want and
you can call it whatever you want to
yourself but i just don't want daisy's
1.5 million subscribers
walking away thinking that this is what
their intuition will inherently
accomplish
it's very clear that most influencers
using this terminology just don't really
understand it at all
themselves and that's okay i mean we're
all learning right so i just want to
provide that education all right let's
see what else she has to say
right now i'm trying to get a little bit
leaner in general just because i feel a
lot better when i'm leaner so like i
said i've been incorporating some cardio
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to eat a carb before my workout
and then a carb after my workout that
i've been cutting out one carb
throughout the day a case in point
cutting out one carb throughout the day
to get leaner not
intuitive eating
again i have nothing against dieting or
manipulating macros or counting calories
to meet a goal if that is what brings
you joy
everyone is entitled to body autonomy
and you can do whatever you want to try
to achieve whatever aesthetic goal that
you have i'm not here to judge daisy on
that but this is blatant diet culture so
you know please let's not pretend that
it's not i want to see what she's eating
though i have my sourdough toast cooking
in the oven
so cute and yes i eat sourdough toast i
don't think it's honestly that bad if
you just have one and you're about to go
workout so you're gonna go burn it off
anyways oh
okay well you guys know i love my
sourdough i just think it's like the
most flavorful bread and because it's a
fermented food it's naturally lower in
fodmaps so it's easier to digest so i
love her choice in morning carbs
but
obviously
i don't love her choice in words
so fyi folks contrary to daisy's
assertion it's also not bad if you have
two slices of bread or if heaven forbid
you have bread and you don't work out
afterwards to burn it off
for the love of all that is holy
bread is not the devil
please let me put this into perspective
for you so two slices of sourdough bread
contains just 170 calories 3 grams of
fiber 6 grams of protein and just under
30 grams of carbs 30 grams of carbs is
just like 10 to 20 percent of your carb
needs for the entire day
it's nothing and daisy's suggesting that
you know she can only have one and only
because she's exercising that day
friends
eat the damn bread eat it jim eat it
phyllis and know not just if you're
going to work out anyways
i'm getting a little unhinged here but
let's see what she's having with said
bread i am cutting up an avocado and i'm
going to squeeze a
ton of lemon bacon this is just organic
uncured turkey bacon just a little bit
of this vegan butter on my sourdough
toast and this is what my beautiful meal
looks like
okay so this looks like a tasty albeit
relatively small breakfast um but we
have a little carbs in the sourdough
some protein in the turkey bacon and
some fats in the vegan butter and
avocado
now i looked up that uncured turkey
bacon and despite what the label of
these natural nitrate-free bacons may
suggest they still do contain nitrates
so food manufacturers still cure their
nitrate-free bacon or turkey breast but
they rely on natural curing agents like
celery powder in lieu of synthetic
sodium nitrate it says so in itty bitty
letters on the label right here
and while we don't have any quality
research to suggest that natural
nitrates are healthier than synthetic
ones
most experts think the effect is likely
the same and actually there is some
concern that you might even be getting
more nitrates in nitrate-free foods
since synthetic nitrate amounts are
regulated and capped whereas the amount
of celery powder a food can contain
is not having said that i don't think
that we need to sensationalize or
demonize anything here there are
naturally occurring nitrates in all
sorts of foods we consume most notably
in vegetables and if you're consuming
processed foods in moderation
it shouldn't really be a huge concern
so this turkey bacon does have
about half the sodium of most bacons
i've seen so it looks like a pretty good
choice assuming that it tastes okay but
ultimately i say that there's always
room for moderate amounts of ultra
processed foods like bacon in your diet
when the bulk of your diet is from whole
unprocessed foods
overall diet quality is much more
important to me
than any singled out ingredient when it
comes to achieving long-term good health
so if daisy loves this bacon great
turkey baking it up but it's just worth
pointing out that
if you're trying to avoid nitrates
it is still a prominent source
but anyway back to the breakfast if
there's a snack coming up then this is
totally great and fine but
if this is daisy's only fuel until the
afternoon with a workout in there
i would probably want to see this bulked
up so maybe another slice of toast or
some eggs in there or some yogurt with
fruit anyways
let's keep going i also have this big
giant
jug of water i've been trying to drink
more just because i feel better it's
better for your skin this is my energy
drink i don't specifically drink ilani
new um
sometimes all celsius okay so
all water is good water in my books i
mean assuming it's clean and safe to
drink but i am pleasantly surprised to
see that she drinks her water
plain
and without a side of pseudoscience on
the alleged benefits of lemon water but
anyways whatever you like lemon water
lime water water water it's all good but
she is also right that water is
important for your skin
and while one large systematic review of
the literature suggested that the
evidence we do have
is weak at best
it did find that for those who were
dehydrated drinking more water did
reduce skin dryness and improve
elasticity as for her energy drink this
one has zero added sugar and about 200
milligrams of caffeine which is the same
amount as about two cups of coffee now
it's important to note that energy
drinks have been the subject of
countless public health campaigns there
are over 20 000 trips to the emergency
room in the u.s every single year from
energy drink use alone now the biggest
risk however is in younger kids people
with heart or anxiety issues and folks
who mix energy drinks with alcohol
now the other thing to consider is that
a lot of energy drinks are regulated as
supplements and if you watch my video on
the supplement industry you'll know that
that means they are
not really regulated well at all
so yeah it's kind of just like buyer
beware out there for sure let's see what
else she has to say
my skin
has been through some [ __ ] you guys so i
started seeing this new lady and she's
putting me on these like vitamins and
stuff vitamin d3
drops
it tastes really good so i try not to do
like put the whole thing
on just like a drop or so maybe two so i
am a huge believer in the power of
vitamin d i think i think we're just
scratching the surface with our
understanding of all of its important
roles but we do actually have some early
evidence to suggest that vitamin d
supplementation can improve acne
particularly in those who are deficient
in vitamin d
and since so many of us are legitimately
deficient it's definitely worth speaking
to your doctor about your unique vitamin
d needs and that's true whether you're
suffering from acne or not i am going to
have some of my coconut charcoal this is
good for your gut and i've been told a
lot of acne comes from your gut
sometimes and then i just chose that
because if i have anything else with
charcoal like i will literally die like
my stomach will
rip apart oh
i thought the activated charcoal trend
was dead
wishful thinking on my part but if you
are wondering about the efficacy of
consuming burnt coconut shells wood and
bamboo
let me give you a quick 101
so activated charcoal is traditionally
used to pull toxins out of the stomach
in the er when someone comes in having
poisoned themselves
it's unpleasant stuff and really only
something that you would normally want
to take if you were desperate and maybe
dying but of course wellness culture
made it cool again with the belief that
it will help bind toxins in your gut
and flush them out now the research in
this area for gut health hasn't been so
clear
it's possible that it has a very slight
benefit for bloating and gas for those
with an overgrowth of hydrogen-producing
bacteria
but the research is poor and study
results have been mixed what we do know
is that activated charcoal doesn't
discriminate what it binds onto so even
if it did theoretically
bind so-called toxins
it also could bind and excrete things
that we would actually want to keep in
our body so things like nutrients
vitamins supplements you're paying money
for and medication that you actually
need
so imagine you're taking the birth
control pill to prevent an unwanted
pregnancy
you take a charcoal pill because i don't
know an influencer said too
and well
you know the rest
[Music]
so activate charcoal can also cause
dehydration so it's very important to up
your water if you do decide to take it
ironically water on its own is likely a
more reliable and safer detoxing tool
than charcoal supplements and it doesn't
cause diarrhea constipation vomiting and
digestive blockages that supplements
like these do so obviously please always
speak to a doctor before trying them
yourself as for daisy's assertion that
acne comes from your gut
we do know that like virtually
everything
skin health is often somewhat of a
reflection of the health of our
microbiome
we also know that what you eat may have
an impact on your skin
this is a really complicated area of
research and one that we are just still
starting to really learn about but for
example
research suggests that the typical low
fiber westernized diet is associated
with changes to the intestinal
microbiome which in turn can result in
inflammatory skin conditions like acne i
have a whole video about diet and acne
so if you are suffering from regular
breakouts i definitely suggest watching
that right here so if you want
perfect abs just do this okay guys i
will say like look at my abs like they
have been coming in so much more lately
i really think it's because i've been
doing more cardio and more ab exercises
um
probably not i'm sure what daisy's about
show us is a very good workout but there
is no one exercise or exercise program
that will give everyone perfect abs
in reality one's ability to get a
six-pack is largely genetic and also
depends on achieving a very low body fat
percentage which is unlikely to achieve
from crunches alone most women need to
get down to 10 to 15 body fat before
they can see those abs appear and for a
lot of us
that is just not only not sustainable
but it's not necessarily even healthy to
maintain either
experts suggest that 11 body fat is the
critical level for menstruation and
anything below that is likely to cause
amenorrhea
and while some folks might think well i
hate my period so that's kind of nice
it's not when the long-term risk is
osteoporosis and endometrial cancer so
yeah
i do feel strongly about this one
because
this look might come easily for some
women but it could require very
dangerous behaviors for others
so let's focus on what is actually
healthy here and that is exercising for
core strength so daisy's workouts look
awesome and are no doubt beneficial
whether or not they result in perfect
abs let's see what else she's eating
frozen spinach a whole banana and i'm
doing a whole banana because i just
worked out usually i do half if i didn't
just work out some almond butter some
almond milk whey protein powder some l
glutamine for recovery
okay so this looks like a great
post-workout smoothie we've got carbs
from the banana protein in the protein
powder healthy fats in the nut butter
and even some veggies in there
but since there is some banana shaming
going on
i do want to point out that the carbs in
one banana
is not even what i would consider
optimal for post-workout recovery
there's about 30 grams of carbs and 30
grams of protein in this smoothie which
is about a one to one ratio of carbs to
protein when we actually ideally would
want to see about three to one carbs to
protein
obviously this is no big deal and
totally fine if this is what tastes
really good to her
but no need to talk about the poor
banana like it's some kind of indulgent
treat
bananas are nature's exercise bestie
they're packed with easily digestible
carbs plus potassium and the perfect
vessel for driving protein into the
muscle stat
and even if you're not working out
it's okay to eat the whole thing
half a banana has only like 50 calories
and like 15 grams of carbs
not something to ever stress about ever
even if you sat on your ass and binged
netflix all day so personally i would
add some more carbs either with some
more fruit maybe some oats a side of
bread oatmeal dates something to beef
this up because yeah this does feel kind
of limited for a post-workout snack that
is also a meal
as for the addition of l-glutamine the
evidence suggests that it doesn't
necessarily affect body composition but
it may help with strength recovery from
resistance training so if she feels that
it's working well for her it works for
me
just of course a reminder to always look
for a third party tested supplement and
again i've got a whole video to help
guide you on that right here anyways
let's see what's next we got some
chicken rice green beans
and a little like a nut glaze on top
this meal looks delicious so yeah it
definitely looks like the girl's mom
knows how to cook i don't know what a
pecan sauce nut glaze is but it sounds
so
good so we've got protein in the chicken
carbs in the rice healthy fats in the
pecans and some veggies in the beans so
that to me is textbook balance and i'm
here for it okay so before we get into
the stats a quick trigger warning that
i'm about to talk macros and calories so
feel free to skip ahead if needed to the
next section on the time stamp below so
based on my calculations daisy's
consuming just 1470 calories with 27
from protein 43 from carbs and 30 from
fat considering that this is just not
enough food she's also coming up short
in most of her micronutrients as well
most notably a bunch of the b vitamins
iron fiber and even vitamin c which
honestly
i don't think i've ever seen outside of
my review of
maybe this guy i also watched another
one of her wedding days from a few
months ago and i think there was even
less on that day so it does feel like
this is maybe her usual routine now what
i like about daisy's diet is that it's
pretty simple and accessible her meals
while
sparse
are easy to replicate and relatively
accessible so even the dinner that her
mama made looked pretty simple and
inexpensive to make which i always am
here for but i want to switch gears and
offer a few gentle nutrition tips
specific to her current
intake so for an active young woman
working out most days of the week
daisy likely needs at least 2000 to 2200
calories for weight maintenance alone
now considering her goal of maintaining
a big booty i would think that she
wouldn't want to cut her gains so
significantly with over a 500 calorie
deficit i know she mentions wanting to
get leaner but i would be worried that a
caloric deficit equivalent to about a
pound of weight loss per week
may interfere with muscle maintenance
required to stay lean and keep her
metabolism working well i have no issues
with weight loss goals or body
composition goals this is her body and
she deserves the autonomy to do whatever
she wants with it but just as a
nutrition professional
this protocol
does seem at odds with her goals
now with that in mind i would love to
see some more substantial meals and
snacks in her day
so if we really break it down
daisy has had a relatively small
breakfast of one piece of avocado toast
a post-workout smoothie with just 30 to
40 grams of carbs and a modest size yet
balanced dinner that was it
honestly i had to go back and watch the
video like a bunch of times because i
was sure i must have been missing
something but alas
she was the one missing out if she's
legitimately not more hungry on a diet
like this
i might suggest cutting out the energy
drink altogether a lot of people use
energy drinks diet drinks coffee and tea
to blunt their hunger cues and to
provide them with an experience of
energy when the real true energy from
calories is lacking
also considering there was very little
produce in this day and her fiber intake
was a little bit low
i would love to see a little more
veggies and fruit in her meals or snacks
she did mention the importance of gut
health and that she was taking an
activated charcoal supplement
specifically for that so i am surprised
that she isn't prioritizing good quality
fiber sources throughout her day having
said that here's what i would suggest
breakfast
we can buff this up we could simply just
add another piece of avocado toast or
maybe throw some eggs into the mix for
some extra protein or she could serve
that up with some greek yogurt if she
eats dairy and some fruit
lunch
well i don't know a protein smoothie
is just not lunch in my books
so if she wanted to time her workout to
have this immediately after
great
but i would suggest serving it with some
additional carbs to help replenish those
glycogen stores so that might mean
adding a bowl of oatmeal a small
sandwich a simple wrap or pita a hearty
grain-based salad or some veggies pita
and hummus
i think this could also serve as a
really good opportunity to sneak in some
extra veg
now her dinner looks great maybe a
little bit small so i do definitely
think that there's room for a snack
before or after if she wanted even like
a fun food just to make this diet a
little bit more enjoyable and
sustainable for the long run so now
let's switch gears and talk about
daisy's relationship with her food and
body and i'm really going to try to be
succinct because
i feel that there could be a lot to
unpack i think my biggest beef is the
title of this video
what to eat in day for a flat tummy and
a big booty yes what you eat how you eat
and how you exercise can absolutely
change the shape of your body
but your genetic predisposition plays a
much more significant role
just consider the fact that like every
influencer i've ever reviewed has eaten
avocado toast and protein shakes and
every one of them looks different
this is not like a magical combo of food
that's going to result in a kim k
hourglass body for everyone there are
other videos on daisy's channel with a
similar issue i would say
honestly the one called wedding a day
for a small waist should likely be
retitled what i in a day to keep my body
fat low enough that you can see some
abdominal definition and i was naturally
born with a low waist to hip ratio
but
sadly
i don't think youtube allows that many
characters now i'm not body shaming the
girl i think she's beautiful and
obviously this is a very desirable body
composition so
girl
i say work it but i'm just pointing this
out because apparently i have to remind
a lot of young impressionable viewers
that even if you replicated this diet to
a tea and i really don't think that you
should for all of its shortcomings but
your body wouldn't magically look like
hers i also want to reiterate that i am
all for aesthetic body composition goals
everyone is entitled to want to change
their body or look a certain way and
whether that requires a committed
exercise and diet regimen or surgery
you do you
no judgment from me i definitely don't
have an issue with any of that but i do
want to just correct the misinformation
about her comments on intuitive eating
because what i've observed right here
is not what i would call intuitive
eating there was a lot of moralizing
language around food particularly around
carbs like only allowing herself small
amounts of carbs when she's exercising
because she's going to burn them off
anyway and cutting out one carb a day to
get lean so let's just call this what it
is
this is a diet
maybe it's a flexible diet for her
but it's a diet no less
i don't know her diet history so this
may be a relatively good moment in her
relationship with food so i would say
let's just try to be kind to daisy as
she continues on her journey and folks
that is all that i have for you today if
you like this video be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
on who you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
and for more great videos like this
check out the link right here
you